It's Design Week and our next guest doesn't believe
that you need to break the bank to beautify your home.
She was recognized by "Good Housekeeping"
as an interior designer who is changing the world.
She's the contributing editor
of "House Beautiful", my favorite,
and the founder of Kingston Design Connection.
Please welcome interior designer extraordinaire
Maryline Damour.
(audience applauding)
Hi.
Thank you so much for having me on.
I can't believe I'm here.
Oh my God, I'm so honored.
You are really one of my favorite designers.
I follow everything you do.
What is your biggest design tip?
What's budget friendly design advice?
You know, this is something I tell my clients
all the time that the simplest thing to do is plan ahead.
And we do this as interior designers all the time
in terms of developing mood boards and renderings.
'Cause at the end of the day,
you can change anything on papers as many times as you want
and something as even inexpensive as paint,
if you need to repaint,
that can get pretty costly pretty quickly.
So taking the time to do all of that stuff on paper
means that when you're ready to go,
there are fewer missteps.
All right, well, we're having a new homeowner
with her design dilemma, a few upgrades that are under $30.
Let's take a look!
Hi, Drew. My name is Julie.
I live in Brewster, New York
with my husband and two small boys.
About seven months ago,
we bought our new house and we need help.
The previous owners gifted us this hutch and dining set,
and although it's beautiful, it's just really not our style
and it doesn't work for us in this room.
I would love to get rid of the hutch
except then it leaves this huge blank wall
that I do not know what to do with.
Do you have any tips that could help me maximize the space?
Please help us. We'd be so grateful. Thank you.
Please welcome, Julie Miller!
(audience applauding)
Thank you for coming on the show.
Oh my God, this is great.
Okay.
So Maryline, take us through your suggestions, your insight.
I wanna hear everything. So I'm putting it over to you.
So one of the first things that I did
was to find a lovely floral wallpaper.
So that way your dining room
can be surrounded in springtime.
And we definitely got rid of the hutch.
Okay.
But we wanted you
to keep the storage that you had,
so we brought in these lovely floating shelves.
This is stunning.
And you can see that you can mix them up.
It can be shelving for your dinnerware
as well as books, et cetera.
And we framed it out in lovely framing.
And you have two children, I understand.
I do. Toddler.
(Julie and Maryline laughs)
It's crazy.
Yep.
Crazy time.
I think we should, as a society, agree, it's a buckle up.
Absolutely.
You know, so I'm definitely have the mindset
that we should be creating children's spaces in our homes.
And even if it's an elegant space,
there's an elegant way to include children in our homes.
So one of the ways that I did that
was to bring in a chalkboard at children level.
I love this. Oh my God.
And as you can see... (audience applauding)
Yes, it's so good!
Julie, do you like...
How do you feel?
Ah, I'm dying. Oh my God.
This is just...
And to cook a meal,
like your kids can color while you cook a meal
and not on your table, they can color on this chalkboard.
I love a good game of tic-tac-toe too.
I know.
All right.
What is your vision for the dining table set?
What did you do here?
So your dining table and chair set were dark wood
all of it.
Yes.
Right. So we actually lightened it up.
So that way, your space is light and bright and airy.
And so one of the ways we did that
was through these slip covers.
I don't know why I didn't think of this.
Yeah. And since you-
I needed you.
Yeah, since you have children,
it's easy to swap them out,
throw them in the washing machine.
Maryline, can you buy pre-made slip covers
that kind of generically fit a chair,
if you will.
Yes. Absolutely.
Well, Julie, what do you think?
I'm so in love. Oh my gosh.
Really?
It is like, so...
It is so beautiful. Oh my God.
It is everything. The table...
Oh my God. My Pinterest. This is my Pinterest.
One thing I wanna point out
that we're talking about all throughout the week
that has definitely influenced me as of late as well,
is the pops of black.
I think it's really kind of rising to the top.
Yeah.
Of a really great way to minimalistically,
or as a maximalist, really chic up your space.
(audience applauding)
Yeah, absolutely.
Come on.
Well, I'm so glad you like it 'cause guess what?
You're getting everything.
Oh my God.
All of these is going home with you.
(audience applauding)
Oh my God.
And we're gonna give you $500
to just get it installed, make it all happen.
Oh my God.
Bibbidi-boo. Just everything dialed in.
Thank you so much.
Of course, Julie.
(upbeat music)